hello my name is Alaska and I'm Jeremy
and this is our song aliens came down
today what would they think what would
they say hey will they like what we've
done with the place would they tell us
the secrets of the human race what is
why does it start why build a planet
just to tear it apart the aliens came
down to
[Music]
by
[Music]
[Music]
and you see the gutters over there
[Music]
baby
[Music]
came down from space when they beam me
up and take me away from this place
maybe their galaxy would feel like maybe
I wouldn't
[Music]
maybe there's no
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
I'll just jump in right here we're made
music moment we're on a little amethyst
journey we are are you feeling I'm
feeling a little bit explain the name of
the the record to me amethyst journey
well we wanted to be an A in a J cuz the
last gun Jeremy and it has to be Google
a bowl so that so that people can find
it easily so it's like two words that
people will know kind of how to spell
and they can go they never go together
normally so I love amethyst and Jeremy
loves stones and stuff like that and
journey because it's a bits of process
it go for you go on the journey together
I agree like amethyst sore crystals and
and there's they're so natural and yet
they're so super natural it's a big
picture kind of thing where oh what do
we how do we feel about nature how do we
feel about technology how do we feel
about being humanoids on earth right now
and the ups and downs of that so I
thought it was like an interesting kind
of brain curl what what is name at this
charity anyways like why don't you
listen what if the aliens came down
today what would they think they'd be
like girl just stop it's just girls
start over it's just dawn no be like
just chill out just like chill but they
I mean they would probably not want to
get anywhere near us honestly that's
what that's my that's my theory okay I
heard on the news that the earth has 10
years left if we keep going at our
current rate so like we have to like
start changing things yeah so this talk
is going to save the earth we will leave
it on that
[Music]